[MUSIC]
The number one reason your startup will
fail is going to be a people issue.
There has been several different
data collections on this topic, and
the consensus across different researches
is the vast majority of startups fail.
One of the statistics is nine
out of ten startups fail.
And Noam Wasserman in his book The
Founder's Dilemmas investigated through
a series of interviews and
surveys why these startups fail
to achieve their stated goals.
That the vast majority of those failures,
six of the nine failures were people
issues, there was a fight between
co-founders that torn the company asunder.
It was a lack of agreement about who
was going to be the leader between two
founders, that kept the company
from moving forward.
It was a lack of culture that
created ongoing churn and
an inability for the company to scale.
If you think about it in a startup,
everything that you do,
even choices of which products you want
to make or how how you're going do it,
come back to people, and
the people that you have in the room and
their ability to effectively
make decisions together.
And this comes from things like diversity,
it comes from culture,
it comes from emotional intelligence,
conflict management skills.
In my mind, and again, as a psychologist
I am saying this, everything that you're
going to be doing in your startup
is going to be about the people.
And the sooner that you realize that and
you're as intentional about the people
choices you make in your startup as you
are about the product, the more likely you
are to be that one in ten startups
that actually does make it and
succeeds and becomes a unicorn that
the rest of the world talks about.
[MUSIC]
It's very competitive to find the best
talent and entrepreneurs often say well,
I don't have money, I'm never
going to to be able to get A players.
Well, guess what?
If you create an amazing place to
work that's very mission driven,
you actually can draw in the top talent,
particularly the top talent whose values
and ideas are in line with your own.
And so being very intentional from the
get-go after you have your leadership in
place, idea what you want in the team.
Then also put as much effort
into who we are as a company.
What is our purpose for being?
We have our mission,
that's never going to change.
So that's democratizing manufacturing or
bringing financial knowledge to
the masses, take your choice.
And then having that vision of okay,
what's a really amazing goal we
could have five years down the road?
The best goals, visions, if you will, the
50% chance of success and are visceral.
[MUSIC]
Say if creating beauty in
the world is your top value, and
you're a company that's
bringing artwork to companies.
And then you're going to be looking for
how that person brings beauty into
their own life and
not just how they tell you one on one.
But what are the actual
behaviors they've done?
Did they found a nonprofit organization to
develop local artists in their community?
If you talked to their family,
were they painting at a young age?
But it means investing,
not just in what people have to say to you
when you're at a pitch event, which is,
I feel like, often how founders fall
into co-founding relationships.
But you're going slowly enough
before you apply a co-founder title,
to get to know the people in this person's
life whether it's past coworkers,
even family or friends are really
going to have different points of data,
if you will, on this person.
That are as behavioral and
concrete as possible, and
not just something somebody can say
when they're being glib over a cocktail.
[MUSIC]
Whether you're leading a traditional
team or especially leading a startup,
knowing who you are and what you
bring to the table is so important.
A lot of people don't dare to
look within enough, to come to
terms with those strengths and weaknesses,
so self awareness is everything.
It's also self awareness in terms of
your values and what really drives you.
Doing a startup because
you want to do a startup,
I can almost guarantee it
was never going to work.
Doing a startup because there's a problem
in the world that speaks to your
fundamental values as a human person,
that's going to work.
If you talk to venture capitalists about
the type of CEO or founder they look for,
one of the phrases they get back a lot is
magnetic, and anybody can be magnetic.
It depends if you found your passion.
You found something in the world
that deeply means something to you.
[MUSIC]